[Music]
three two one tension hello welcome to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we and this crew we've been
talking about some crazy conspiracy [ __ ]
all day yeah I can only imagine what we
would talk about when we talk about
whatever we want actually happier things
probably probably things that don't
involve mass conspiracy guys ever do GMT
no no no whatever you talking my DMT
what is that it's you go to like
different dimensions it's like ayahuasca
that's a type yeah it's tomorrow
iOS cos you have to smoke it though
drink it you trick me I would you drink
you drink it like they make it tea with
it and then you vomit alive then you
[ __ ] you transcend or some [ __ ] yeah
and then whereas DMT is like a pill and
it's just clean only doctors trying to
make sure that tea and then he like
after projecting a little bit I guess
what's the hardest core drug you ever
did oooh I expected that from you know
tell me something else yeah can you
isn't it crazy how in our generation we
saw poor prohibition be lifted yeah oh
yeah that's crazy
we lived this air I'm walking stuff on
Disney right now yeah we're watching
yeah 10 things we hate about you that
came out like in 98 99 and the principal
was like or the attention guy was like
I'm taking away this Pope yeah you
smoking dope I'm taking this pot not
like not one of the first places to like
illegal it was in Seattle sorry that
that movie takes place in Seattle I was
like what and they're one of the first
like states that like legalize it don't
in school
dated what are they gonna let everyone
out of jail who did pop yeah they really
should and they should get reparations
yeah you know anyone do that yeah so um
for possession right possession
distribution you know that sort of stuff
yeah
one thing that blew my mind was how
Colorado and all these like other more
conservative states where they eased up
our weed before us Californians did yeah
Colorado's terribly recently but
recently they were still red when they
did it well they smoked some and they
turn blue Obama dude everyone do what
they want yeah well you know any other
reason for that - because I do have
family in a Colorado
yeah and it hasn't always been that way
a lot of people from LA from other
states are getting more expensive San
Francisco that's a huge factor of why
it's turned over the years funny is why
often his law you so like you know did
you know that a lot of people moved into
California back in a day because of like
the Beach Boys and all that [ __ ] and
they're like California wasn't as
inhabited right yeah so everyone here
was like get the [ __ ] back blow coal
Lobby like the locals are pissed right
get the [ __ ] back and then all the same
people that stayed here for generations
are now gentrifying back of the stage
that their [ __ ] family came at home
yeah that's so funny yeah because it's
happening like an organ lying up or
laying is like to shadow Austin I tried
to get JK to move to Vegas but barn G oh
[ __ ] doll they were the most down to do
I know yeah at one point Gio was sending
everybody in the girls Ted it was
sending like houses in Vegas like look
at this I would have never gone I don't
yes 10 bedrooms plus man yeah as a
fellow Japanese man that would ruin the
Domino ruin the magic of I love every
weekend yeah but dude like if I had to
live there I would if I lived there I'm
dying in two months the biodome if I was
living there I'd have to change jobs
like I don't think I could I would still
do the work at the casino no I would I
would do something a firearms probably
what would you do that would kill you
two months [ __ ] orgy zko I don't even
do drugs yeah
I would over gamble man I'll be like one
of the yeah I could see you over again
lonely use all of JK's money and gamble
not a great well it's probably good
thing we didn't move to Vegas that's why
do you ever see people that like I've
lived there for a while too they just
like shriveled like yeah that's the
weather the dryness you guys don't get
sick when you're there I could be there
for like four or five days and I'm
dehydrate my money my not and my [ __ ]
body but you shouldn't say that do you
seven you to them with a downslope
sucking your that's a good part bad
thing in a good way because you get your
balls dried my favorite place in Vegas
is a wicked spoon wicked spins pretty
amazing I agree she ruined she ruined
okay not to doesn't mean anything but
she ruined all the other buffets II went
to I didn't did I made you up great so
what did we do for the like that did it
get better no the company wants me wants
like that real one and then we go oh we
did budget dude yeah so the thing is
that she was like you know he do you go
wait this one's like that first night I
was like oh all right you keep talking
about the clip let me only not what we
want you to you willing me yeah that was
that was great the whole rest of the
trip I was just disappointed but didn't
we go a long time ago I never went with
JK I always went on my own like
sometimes on a JK trip but I'd be like I
really need you know but also I can't do
buffets like I get full really fast oh
you're so bored I told you right the
portion Portugal section like you don't
have to get the bang for your buck you
still have to try so you stay there for
a long time there's a lot of stuff that
you can try first of all I'm pescetarian
and dairy-free
there's a lot of things have a really
like small like I like small meals more
often
oh you're sitting down yeah like I would
still say try it because the variety
that they have at this buffet is real
I think even as a pescetarian you could
find a lot of stuff yeah you could
probably you please $35 for this [ __ ]
to go to a buffet and she gets fruit
here in LA I'll pay $35 in the salad I'm
secure Bellagio [ __ ] crazy loggias
not as good no no no no wicked you got a
do this strategy all right so like you
go toward the end of lunch right when
they're speaking the stuff to dinner so
you get lunch prices you hang out and
talk for an hour and then they start
rolling out the dinner food and you get
up and you start grabbing all the food
but this is the strategy that I do is I
get bite-sized pieces like around that
big of everything so then I can taste
the world
nari that's very smooth he's not lying
you taste the world Emma gets better and
look how someone with IBS is doing this
do by the way this is video brought to
you by wicked spoon bike hacking a
buffet system
they usually have like to our limits a
lot of those places though it's just
like you have it or maybe that's why cuz
people be doing that too many people
caught on your method you could just
hang out we used to just hang out and
wait get hungry again go eat again
do they really kick you out though
they're like give it I've never run out
two hours in a buffet I never have I die
by the end of the first hour so I want
to do other things in Vegas than hang
out in a buffet so I wouldn't want to
stay there for well you never went when
you're under 21
oh girl fun [ __ ] dude you know I did go
we did do buffets when we were under 21
I was thinking now cuz I haven't been 21
for a while the [ __ ] that you do to have
fun under 21 is totally different so
true you just have sex and like and go
try to cause a drink on the street and
walk around
yeah oh well yeah I mean you get alcohol
you stand by the market you have a bomb
by if I was a boring job
okay well that's how you get smokes and
uncle not that I'm recommending this or
you befriend people with an older
brother yeah they buy it for you and
they miss you child one of my favorite
Vegas people watching things is no
matter who you see black white asian
Latino of all different ages and races
they're all holding those yard sticks of
[ __ ]
like yelling at somebody yeah but you
mean by ringing hi yeah
we're over here you know Jesus Christ
that was Byron do you enjoy what I loved
watching they're like complete mess
girls like walking down the street in
heels I'm like you knew this was gonna
happen what do you do it in this [ __ ]
wobbly and she did know oh she like you
knew that the night was gonna end like
this mind you are you throwing the
dreads like giraffe walking funny cuz
after the club you see all of these
girls barefoot yeah yeah dude I saw the
last time I was in Vegas I saw this
grandma who had like one of those
yardsticks around just [ __ ] puking a
solid 70 and then her whole family was
there like like consolee and she's just
[ __ ] yakking into a plan okay grandma
that's the most biggest thing I think
I've seen on this trip crazy old brazen
thing everything it was in San Francisco
and I was like at Downtown and there was
a woman huh Holly 70s a mom was almost
80 with like the dude who was like 30
and they were sucking face whoa yeah it
was the most bizarre thing it was an old
white lady with a black dude whoa
sucking face I was like there is at
least two or three generations between
you guys there's a new thing though like
the old love yeah is it new well it's
more common like she's a senior citizen
like yeah it's aged up pedophilia so
like it's legal because I guess so now
you look like a kid to them
oh so everything is relative i watch the
whole thing about those old ladies going
to Jamaica or Haiti or something like
that and they would have their sugar
boys yeah and it's like these fast
handsome like perfect as dudes right and
they're like with a sweet little grandma
and baby [ __ ] like crazy kiss to all
people are horny as [ __ ] and you could
bust as much as you want to because
they're [ __ ] babies and in homes I
heard that they [ __ ] go oh yeah I've
heard that so recently there was like
this woman algis 68 year old when was
the age he has never heard of the story
I'm the oldest woman to pray yeah oh it
was like she was like it was like Indian
she goes look and they argue is India
and
already had kids and grandchildren
[ __ ] crazy dude [ __ ] up and she's
like oh yeah hey another kid I was like
yo that's [ __ ] scary dude can you
imagine delivering that like being the
doctor being like like they're not
you're not gonna see their kid when he
graduates high school that's so sad he
sure does have to worry about her [ __ ]
being stretched uh
I mean I imagine her bones getting [ __ ]
blow the book FL the pelvis the end of
fellas isn't that baby got powdered milk
coming out of her titty attitude and or
the fact that both of his parents are
probably to die before he like gets into
school yeah oh my god we're not supposed
to have a chilled you right now how do
you that's 60 something years old what a
cruel [ __ ] joke it's just like she
never had a kid before her dream you
know she dreams she never saw anyone
deliver a kid this late before yeah that
was a dream that's a miracle right there
dude that's a [ __ ] killin her dreams
you guys good you were during the break
yeah Vegas no no holidays Oh Bahamas oh
there's a casino where we're going there
- yeah you're invited everyone's invited
by the way we invited everyone every
time we talk about about Europe oh I am
I'll be an ally in Nigeria so I'm going
to the motherland for the first time
ever you're gonna do it is that where
your roots are from West Africa it is I
am Yoruba is the the people that I came
from and I know that because now because
23andme gets way more specific now Oh
girls gonna ask how did you treat your
genius Oh morning my last name is it my
birthday what did I mention at some
point on JK is somewhere but I'll
reiterate in kgo now huh how you
pronounce with me bundling so it's like
saying on the delay but what could be on
it another way it's the Americanized
version of it got messed up it means
born away from home like was what we
thought but now I'm in a Nigerian woman
she's like oh that's not really it your
names actually like bomb me Delhi which
is like slightly different and it means
to return home
so like that home factor is there that
it got you got the full circle oh like
what graduation how many Jenner
relations or you know I'm probably way
way like like I in twittering me it
shows that French and German most likely
brought my family here and that was like
in like the 1700s mm-hmm so you don't
have any family over there not having
direct you know what I know yeah so yeah
so my buddy he is married to a Nigerian
woman and so they for a long time they
were out in Nigeria for like years I
think they were out there for like five
years and then I was like financially
ready to be like oh yeah I'm gonna I'm
ready to go they were like oh we moved
back to LA no I don't want to go alone
and so now they're going back again her
mother mother and that's the same woman
who explains to me like my last name is
I shouldn't have taken wait so how did
you get a Nigerian last name they oh
yeah sorry I didn't mad skipped over
that so when I was born I was born
Antoine William Bailey and then my dad
when I was like seven did research or he
died did research because there's whole
thing about they obviously didn't
because it's an Irish name he figured
that we had I'm sort of like Irish
family that like like owned it's at some
point so he's like [ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm
gonna like get a new last name and he
chose West Africa see because generally
that's where we should have come from
and he just got freakin lucky and
choosing like the actual right tribe and
everything well obviously to he got a
little lazy because he's like eh that's
what I do when I'm researching something
I'm like cuz I write when I write movies
with my buddy Mike we always go through
the alphabet list of names and what we
our names are always a B or C first
letter of the catchy name - I mean it's
not gone from like the ins I just get so
bored so fast and that spark of genius
you should start you should start from
the bottom and go backwards that way I
can tell this genealogy of Steve's a
script writing process from here on out
it'd be like though this is just to
start with Nicki and then maybe I'll get
some on your mineral
know what I do when I write is I
actually have people's names who are a
or Z so I had like my first book my
first book his name is Amana my next
book right now her name is is Halle
so how do you how do you pick the names
is it because of that same [ __ ]
um yeah like when you find like a name
finder I'll look for like you should
jump back and forth African tribe names
I mean yeah that's like I always used
like a so I go let's go see you also use
your family names a lot like he uses the
same character names over as I'm lazy
cuz it's his family cuz let's use the
same names it's easy I don't want to
think about it too long you know I mean
like I just want to get into it and then
also it helps me it helps me identify
with the character exactly exactly I
said you mean like girl number one
yeah you've been in danger boys yeah
there's some Stevie I'm the names in
there name of Ben is my one of my best
friends growing up that was in a gang
yeah the best one was Tyrone oh I like
that one I appreciate that one I
appreciate that one a lot
now that was the name worth spending a
little bit of time I liked I and then
wrong like like wrong so you've never
been Africa before never and it's funny
because I'm gonna go here and then my
mom wants to go to South Africa
Johannesburg on her 50th birthday oh I'm
down I'll go white it you know I have a
friend who's african-american but he's
Chinese born in his South African okay
so he's african-american
can't mammogram over yeah wait so he's a
Chinese dude who was born in South
Africa yeah okay okay got it I got a
nice African yeah emigrated here have
you got his citizenship so that's why he
can I call you my black friend no it's
funny I actually don't respond to that
kind of thing like it when I was in
Japan some guy that was I was at a bar
right
and it was a New Zealand Australian guy
I don't know which cuz I can't tell the
difference so I tried not to like
[ __ ] say anything but he was I was
Halloween and he was dressed up as what
I thought was a soccer player he's like
oh you're soccer players like no rugby
and then he's like what are you dressed
up as a black guy I was like I can do
the visit few ways I
really pissed off or I can just ignore
it and just know that he's like doesn't
know what he just [ __ ] you might be
drunk and I don't have that kind of
racial tension and New Zealand or
whatever right it's like you know what
let me just like not [ __ ] make this
look in the scene and so like we just
continue talking yeah I use a cool guy
like what notwithstanding the [ __ ]
racism you know what though when I
travel I don't bring the American
American thing to do I cause we always
try to impose our wellness on other
people [ __ ] cultural appropriation
Japanese don't give up I love that about
the thing is when we were in Japan right
just was really scared about wearing a
kimono posting it online a bit when you
[ __ ] do that that's what I'm saying
it's almost reverse racism in a way of
work because like Japanese people like
to watch other cultures wear the clothes
and laugh at them yeah cuz it's kind of
like a circus right but then like for a
lot of people now they're ashamed or
even embarrassed or afraid to do that
and post pictures because they get
attacked why you wearing that fund
monumnet
and I'm like dude why do you want to
take away money from tourism they like
they like this [ __ ] that's what I have a
shot based on it so why do you think
that is why do you think that they don't
take it that serious when it comes to
over here where everyone's going [ __ ]
I think for them if they don't have it's
not the same context as the stuff here
like here has a little bit more of a
violent history but it's more of like a
there's a lot more sore spots with that
but if you go into a country like Japan
where it's pretty homogeneous everything
is like that and then that that's their
culture that they get to share with
others it's not a big mixing melting pot
like it isn't the you know one steal no
one is taking credit yeah more like oh
you want to dress like a samurai you
want to dress like a ninja you want to
wear the clothes and like swing your
sword around and have have fun go ahead
but I think out here that there's just
like you know the whole issue with the
Yellow Peril and like you know like in
the in the past they would uh they kind
of made a mockery of it yeah making fun
of it yeah and also taking credit for
stuff like if they're like oh I created
this thing you're just like I mean not
really like I can obviously see where
you're borrowing from you're not really
giving credit to like the people that
are like you know influencing this sort
of stuff I think that's where America
has a lot more sore spots in other
countries because other countries are
just kind of like oh this is just what
everybody looks like you know
I can tell you also from the black
perspective too especially for a black
women I think there was a music video I
think with either KP a toast with one of
those like white singers whatever and
they like have braid their hair or like
did red along something like that and it
was Deena's like oh how stylish how cool
but then like if we do it now you can
have a job you know that kind of thing
so that that's where the hurt kind of
comes from because there's like it's
that double standard yeah there's a
double standard that's not there that
you don't really get in Japan because
again it's like everyone's like that's
why there was the black and beautiful
movement in the 60s where they go with
the fro and that unique natural thing
prior to that black people were pressing
eros flicking their hair back and
everything yeah does using Malcolm X
went through that evolution actually
when he first started as read when he
was known as read
he said you slick backing of his hair so
like that and then he went to gel and
then got you know nation Islam kind of
assure to him and then he went to being
natural and that was like the thing that
he did it's like a natural evolution I
think black people kind of go through so
the forced assimilation but at the same
time if Y people in the past did it
would mimic the culture it was approved
so I guess that's where that's where the
hurt comes from that was like that's
what it is Rumaki [ __ ] right what did
you think of that instead of the time
where there's this white guy that had
dreads and that's completely stupid well
okay that's all different subject
entirely because because dreadlocks or
just been the the act of locking your
hair is a human or people don't
understand a contact yet so what
happened in stone let's leave the
context yes sorry sorry about that
you're right yes I know so so there's
the incident where this this white guy
who had red lock of his hair and he was
confronted by two black students he's
just well I think yams too but the one
but the one was very active on talking
to him but then the other one was there
to like back her up but she was
basically they say is like oh you know
you like you know you can't wear this
yeah she's saying you were appropriating
my culture and second I think so what do
you think about that's this this is very
different that I feel about the
dreadlocks been with some other things
like kwon ryeol is do you like that but
when it comes to dreadlocks that is a
human trait you can see it back from
like that the Indian what is the name of
that religious group where they also
lock their hair you you see it in
Norseman norsu yeah I know what you're
talking about it's a natural human thing
but again it's that hurt that's coming
back so that context is this a
african-american woman that's dealing
with a situation who she I'm sure in the
has been like ridicule for her hair and
seeing this this why do you just like
loeli loeli Dom wearing it like not
really in the [ __ ] she projected onto
him you not even have a question because
I I've always wondered this and like
since being introduced to culture
appropriation and all that stuff so I
grew up in a beach town where black
white whatever people had dreads yeah
would you still consider that
appropriation if like everyone's kind of
working at the same jobs everybody is
like no well I think honestly is
[ __ ] mostly like I think that is a
[ __ ] argument to bring up in most
cases that's why I said I love Japan so
much because there's none of that kind
of culture there at all and I think to
have progress you have to have it where
everyone is becoming okay with everyone
else's in red mixing and matching like
we had this ideology of America that
we're supposed to be this melting pot
but really we're like a solid that
everyone has a separate a there's like a
yeah yeah water oil kind of thing and I
don't think we get that progress unless
we are actively mixing and appreciate
other people's cultures and you know do
we have any technology yeah there's so
much borrowing that happens here in
America anyway so no culture can really
claim one or the other I think but I
think also to like just discount other
people's experiences based on like what
you think is like oh that you know you
like you said like most most
appropriations [ __ ] but if someone
has the feelings about that be like yeah
I get that I understand sharing
experiences doing this to like be it
like I'm doing this and I think context
matters a lot like oh absolutely
and Antoine what you just said about how
appropriation silly my black friend
doesn't agree well I'm sure the black
meanie does not agree on this [ __ ]
thing at all or we don't agree on most
things why when people say like no blood
community I'm like what the [ __ ] is
actually we just wanted to say my black
thank you thank you very much [ __ ]
funny
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]